all right this is big right now Khloe
Kardashian and how she looks dude I mean
this is this is the chocolate face it's
just where you get conspiracies where
it's like who did Khloe die and they
just put this new person in because this
is the craziest thing I've ever seen not
didn't do me a favor bring up old Khloe
Kardashian picture tell me it's the same
person
dude Isis how crit that that that
doesn't do dust justice now get older
clothes you older chlorite Khloe was a
[ __ ] starting left tackle for the
Colorado Buffaloes she was so big dude
look at that
think how far science and medicine has
advanced but I gotta be honest with you
the new version of her does not look
like that doesn't look like a human brow
Brendan does that look like a human
being
looks like a human odd to have sexual
resolve but it does it look at the eyes
look very closely at the eyes should be
an alien I'd still think okay it looks
like something's wrong like you'd like
that's crazy how so I mean it just
doesn't she did Kathy Griffin this is
the same thing
she doesn't look alive anymore this is
not like old cattle you're like a new
Kathy I wasn't looking it's like that
movie get how it looks alive it's like a
movie get out something's wrong look at
you look dude she looks alive there she
might not want to [ __ ] her she looks a
lot by Brandt there she looks alive
shoots alive and the other thing the
other that doable there something's off
it looks like the movie get out Sean
took Chloe's brain and put in some hot
[ __ ] let's get out Wow insisted to show
you what medicine can do yeah man I
don't know that you might have sold her
soul the devil but that's okay I guess
it's worth it
alright she's so skinny now let me see
her full body they showed here I think
the last thing she did was run Jen and a
black girl she went chocolate body it's
like the last thing she's not tan there
mmm
it's just her running do Brockie never
ran in a gated community
I mean it's god bless her but good for
her man
good for her I mean I'm glad she lost so
that way but I mean she's a pretty girl
I don't know why you need to go crazy
with the face she's pretty hot there
look at all the comments there's yes
baby there she is
yeah I mean she does look pretty damn
amazing right here doesn't know like you
said it didn't look real it just doesn't
look real my fashions it doesn't look
like human being I mean even the tits
look weird like yes right her looks and
she's also can we she also has the skin
of sexy Yama
she's also gold this that's not natural
color now she's also a gold bronze shape
no that's plenty what's that makeup on
the body really yeah a lot of girls do
that now where they have like body
shimmer that's what it was like gold and
bronze on dude where's when is this
gonna be done - Rob Kardashian I mean
when is Rob Rob knife all of the night
sued Rob's 400 pounds yeah he tried come
up with the sock business yeah no one
supported it poor rot me robber outside
Denny's in Huntington Beach with guns
saying open now no one supports rod man
they're like geez what's wrong with Rob
he's the black sheep of family well I
don't know maybe does he even have an
Instagram I have taken a photo of that
guy in like years I think that's so
fat-shamed then also like they were
sitting around the mom was or straight
or constraining the businesses she was
right Rob
so socks for you yeah you'll get socks
this poor guy limit mamacita limited
edition I did how how meanwhile this is
a horrific situation emo sisters are
signed with [ __ ] Adair he does
they're billionaires dude dude I love
that go through all the houses
they all own and then they're like Rob
sleeps on one of their couches you know
what I'm still sad about [ __ ] in Lamar
oh I'm just eating Papa John's in
someone's backyard
yes now fathers I know that's the old
one
there's an old one man he's had a tough
go man
he's got a tough go what happened to him
I think his sister got famous for
[ __ ] a dude I mean really man man in
that world Bruce Jenner date
Lamar Odom they want me well I knew less
is the most Pro all have issues and
you're around that and your father was a
successful lawyer yeah you're making
socks yeah you gotta be very careful
around these ladies one bad break away
from making don't [ __ ] with cats to
Scott Disick somehow made it because
he's like a Long Island it's got this
like slime ball he figured that she has
a good brand called you talentless yeah
it's a clothing brand called talentless
it's actually a really good gear I love
it yeah I mean I always liked him me too
yeah he's good that is because we're
scum yeah that's fair yeah I've always
[ __ ] with uh I've always [ __ ] with
him
yeah we're scum I mean you know I get
him I what's he supposed to do like I
get it he just he gave man married into
an attractive a like a wealthy family
bull the spirits died that stuff that is
tough yeah I respect I let him nothing
I mean hustle as a hustle hustle man
yeah he's a hustle he's making the best
I respect that man yeah I've always put
long island god I cannot I cannot
support Long Island happy birthday the
best guy I know Rob Kardashian well want
your [ __ ] help I'm out where is he
where is he he's making me stop right
now Rob no Scott what about Rob what if
he's just getting like super jazzed
right now during quarantine and he's
waiting to just come to his sister's
have all the connections these sisters
Connie got lightbulbs wars and whether
you put them under the night dude get
some [ __ ] cheek implants put them on
to that night we'll see that I bet soon
I mean how great would it be if the next
photo is Rob Kardashian it looks like
Khloe toe like this is Rob Kardashian
it's a picture of a guy that's not even
who's gonna picture the top left the
very first picture what is that the old
app time flies I stay home oh God
gotcha I'll tell you this right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]